hasta ahorita ya vimos cómo le puede
hacer el banco de la reserva federal
para que por medio de transacciones en
el mercado abierto de pagarés del
gobierno se pueda modificar la oferta de
dinero pero a lo mejor me puedes decir
hey sabes que o sea está muy padre esto
pero cuando yo leí el periódico no leí
nada de transacciones en el mercado
abierto sino que leí acerca de ajustar
la tasa de fondos federales o la tasa
objetivo o la tasa de descuento que son
estas tasas y cómo se relacionan con
estas operaciones en el mercado abierto
para pues ahorita vamos a platicar un
poquito acerca de eso ahorita nos vamos
a enfocar en la tasa objetivo y después
no sé en uno o dos vídeos vamos a hablar
de la tasa de descuento estas dos tasas
son conceptos pues distintos pero en
realidad están muy relacionadas entre sí
casi siempre van de la mano sin embargo
ahorita nos vamos a enfocar en la tasa
objetivo pues es la forma en la cual el
banco de la reserva federal establece en
condiciones normales su política
monetaria entonces la tasa objetivo nada
más para darte una definición así muy en
bruto es la tasa en la cual el banco de
la reserva quiere que los bancos se
presten entre sí así
de un día para otro bueno pues qué
quiere decir esto para eso dibuje aquí
dos bancos un poquito diferente claro a
la izquierda están los activos la cosa
en la caja roja es el pasivo y esto en
azul de aquí es el capital lo que hice
diferente es que pues bien hasta ahorita
en todos los vídeos había dibujado las
reservas en la parte de hasta abajo del
lado del activo eso hacía que fuera un
poco complicado comparar las reservas
con el lado del pasivo de las cuentas de
cheques ahorita estoy suponiendo que el
banco no tiene otro tipo de pasivos en
no pidió ningún préstamo todo esto en la
caja roja son puras cuentas de cheques
bueno la cosa es que finalmente me di
cuenta que era más fácil comparar el
pasivo con las reservas si los dibujaba
al lado al lado va digamos que entonces
este banco tiene sus reservas aquí
marcadas en verde éstas podrían ser así
literalmente billetes o efectivo que
ahorita está metido en la bóveda o bien
podrían ser depósitos en una cuenta de
cheques en el banco de la reserva
federal en el fondo son básicamente lo
mismo porque puedes fácilmente cambiar
de una a otra ahora nada más para
aclarar una cosita este activo de aquí
este activo es un pasivo para la reserva
federal
a lo mejor es no sé cómo este cachito de
aquí eso de ahí es un activo para el
banco pero pasivo para la reserva de
modo similar esta reserva de acá también
es un pasivo para la reserva federal si
este pasivo fuera así efectivo entonces
tendríamos un pasivo de notas bancarias
pendientes por otro lado si esto fuera
una cuenta de cheques con el banco de la
reserva
entonces acá tendríamos una cuenta
exigible pendiente para el banco ve muy
bien con esto dicho y bueno al menos en
la forma en la que lo dibujé a ver
espérame tantito deja coloreo para que
se vea más bonito ahora si este banco
este banco así como lo dibujé al parecer
tiene un coeficiente de reserva más
pequeño que el del otro banco esto de
aquí son sus depósitos exigibles lo de
acá son las reservas y no sea así como a
ojo de buen cubero supongamos que la
razón de reservas osea de esta altura
entre esta altura es de que es como de
10% se va y este otro de acá parece que
tiene pues como 20% en reservas
ahora recordando un poquito acerca de
las regulaciones de reservas pues
siempre los bancos tienen que apartar
tantito por si las dudas vaya incluso
aunque no existieran regulaciones los
bancos tienen que guardar tantito en
caso de que las personas vinieran y de
ahí quisieran pedir su efectivo va
entonces siempre quieres guardar un
poquito de reservas sin embargo no
quieres guardar demasiado en reservas
porque nadie te va a pagar interés por
las reservas que estás guardando no
hemos hablado mucho de eso sin embargo
si te da un poco de curiosidad justo así
el banco central puede pagar sus
operaciones o sea el banco central le
abre sus cuentas a los bancos pero no
les pagan nada de interés por ello si es
justo así como lo oyes el banco central
no paga interés en el lado derecho de su
hoja de balance vaya no paga interés por
su pasivo pues o sea por estas cosas de
acá no paga interés por este pasivo pero
si recibe interés por un poco de sus
activos mira aquí dibuje un poquito de
oro esta cosa en amarillo es oro quizás
debería escribirle por aquí que es
oro y luego en este color así como café
vamos a suponer que son pagarés del
gobierno todos los pagarés del gobierno
te pagan interés entonces si soy el
banco de la reserva federal no estoy
pagando nada de intereses en esto de acá
en estos pasivos pero si estoy
recibiendo interés por mis activos eso
está raro no parece que es así como
dinero fácil bueno lo que está
sucediendo en el fondo es lo siguiente y
de hecho esto que te voy a contar es una
de las razones por las cuales no se
entiende muy bien si es una institución
independiente del gobierno o no porque
pues finalmente la mesa directiva la
elige el gobierno pero lo que que va a
decir es que este dinero que que el
banco federal hace cualquier excedente
se va al congreso sea todo ese dinero
después de pagar todos los gastos se va
al congreso vaya no es como que una
institución privada se esté llevando
todo el país todo va de regreso al
congreso sin embargo también pasa al
revés si la mesa directiva hace muchas
estupideces y causa crisis financieras
entonces es el congreso el que tiene que
responder porque ya vimos que está
moneda está respaldada por el gobierno
es un arma de dos filos
va entonces aunque es una institución
independiente pues en ciertos sentidos
no lo es si es parte del congreso oa lo
mejor debería de decir más bien parte
del gobierno bueno con eso dicho sabes
que creo que más bien debería de decir
que es parte de la tesorería no quiero
dar por aquí una idea incorrecta bueno
con esto dicho regresemos al ejemplo de
los dos bancos este banco de acá al
parecer tiene más reservas de las que
necesita y no está padre tener eso
porque no obtienes intereses entonces no
sé supongamos que se da cuenta que tan
solo con el 15 por ciento de reservas ya
la arma por otro lado no sé a lo mejor
éste se da cuenta que está arriesgando
sé mucho y que también le convendría
tener 15 por ciento y entonces le
gustaría tomar prestado esta cantidad
ésta cantidad de reservas otra vez esto
puede ser efectivo o depósitos en
reservas y este monito tiene no se tiene
pues como esto para prestar va entonces
aproximadamente tiene esta cantidad para
prestar como sólo hay dos bancos en este
universo la solución obvia es que este
banco le preste a este de acá y
probablemente sea sólo por una noche
porque no sabes qué va a pasar
a lo mejor al día siguiente va haber más
personas que quieran pedir su dinero
pero si ves que todo marcha bien
el préstamo puede seguir en pie no sé
este banco puede renovar su pedida de
préstamo y el otro bueno creo que es la
idea más bien la pregunta es qué interés
este banco le va a cobrar a este otro
banco qué interés le va a cobrar por
prestarle esta cantidad de dinero
este cachito de dinero de aquí por
prestarle este cachito de dinero por una
noche a este banco de acá pues no sé
supongamos que ahorita la situación está
en que este banco le va a cobrar un 10%
de interés por prestarle el dinero por
la noche entonces le va a cobrar 10% por
prestar esta cantidad de dinero por la
noche ojo o sea no es como que en la
noche le cobre 10% más bien esta es una
tasa anual y ya sabes le cobraría esto a
la 1 entre 365 si en realidad es una
cantidad pues muy chiquita si nada más
por una noche
esta tasa anual sería hacia el banco
pide prestado noche tras noche durante
todo un año vale entonces pensamos qué
sucede si el banco de la reserva
cree que ahorita no hay suficiente
oferta de dinero y entonces hay que
expandir esta oferta vamos a ver qué
sucede recordemos cómo iba este
mecanismo
era para empezar el banco de la reserva
e imprimir billetes imprimía algo de
efectivo si vamos a pensar que esas que
son las impuros billetes para que sea
fácil entonces se imprime algunos
billetes esté ahí ahorita es un activo
para el banco federal pero por supuesto
tiene un pasivo correspondiente que son
notas bancarias pendientes notas
bancarias pendientes verdad y luego y
luego lo que el banco federal hace con
estos billetes es que va a comprar
pagarés del gobierno federal o sea va a
comprar deuda libre de riesgo como ya
platicamos en el vídeo pasado esto de
aquí lo va a realizar en el mercado
abierto entonces se lo puede comprar
pues a mi abuelita oa china o no sé tal
vez a ti o incluso se lo podría comprar
a uno de estos bancos de por acá y vaya
en realidad no importa a quien se lo
compren lo que importa es que toma sus
billetes y con eso compra pagarés del
gobierno federal a ver entonces en la
hoja de balance ahora él
a parte está en pagarés y la pregunta es
qué le sucedió al efectivo donde está el
efectivo pues es efectivo justo va a dar
con tu abuelita entonces ya tu abuelita
tiene el efectivo y qué va a hacer con
ese efectivo pues lo que hace cualquier
persona va y lo mete al banco y claro o
sea lo mejor se lo compraron a muchas
abuelitas entonces no sé digamos que
algunas abuelitas meten el dinero que
algunas de las abuelitas meten el dinero
meten el dinero en este banco voy a
intentar dibujarlo entonces ahora este
banco va a tener más reservas y el resto
de las abuelitas lo depositan en este
banco de por acá va entonces
reflexionemos un poquito con qué sucedió
cuál fue el efecto neto de estas
operaciones número 1 la hoja de balance
del banco central creció el banco
federal aumentó tanto sus activos como
sus pasivos algunos de sus activos se
convirtieron en pagarés y después voy a
hablar cómo esto afecta el interés de
los pagarés federales pero al final de
cuentas entró más efectivo dentro más
efectivo al sistema bancario y lo de
siempre ya sabes puede ser en billetes o
puede ser en cuentas con el banco de la
reserva federal y los dos bancos que
pasó con ellos para pues este banco de
acá así de repente necesita menos dinero
necesita menos reservas esto fue porque
obtuvo reservas adicionales con los
depósitos de nuestras abuelitas y este
otro banco de acá bueno este paso de
tener un 10 por ciento a no sé digamos
12 por ciento de reservas obtuvo algunos
depósitos así en
y éste pasó de no sé digamos de 20% a
22% entonces ahora este banco necesita
menos dinero verdad su demanda de dinero
disminuyó o vaya pues su demanda de
efectivo su demanda de reservas pues y
este otro banco de acá pues también
aumentaron sus reservas antes tenía un
excedente y ahora tiene un excedente más
grande entonces en el sistema bancario
la oferta de dinero aumento a la oferta
de dinero del banco que prestaba aumento
y por otro lado la demanda del banco que
tomaba prestado ha disminuido entonces
ahora para que se lleve a cabo la
transacción como aumentó la oferta y
bajó la demanda pues tiene que bajar el
precio del préstamo y cuál es el precio
de prestar dinero pues la tasa de
interés va entonces para que ahora
suceda la transacción como este monito
de acá necesita menos dinero y a este le
urge más poder prestar su dinero pues la
tasa tiene que bajar digamos a 8%
ahora a lo mejor el banco federal tiene
cierto objetivo quiere una tasa objetivo
de 5% y entonces quieren ver una
realidad en la cual este banco le presta
a este otro con una tasa de interés del
5% que tendrían que hacer pues
exactamente lo mismo es decir otra vez
tenían que ir e imprimir billetes pero
creo que ahorita se me acabó el tiempo
bueno es rápido es imprimir más billetes
con esos billetes comprar pagarés
entonces el dinero entra al sistema la
demanda de dinero disminuye y como hay
más reservas entonces la tasa en la cual
los bancos se prestan entre sí tiene que
disminuir en fin nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo